my name is Ashley and today I'm gonna
test some of the most pinned Halloween
foods from Pinterest every year
Pinterest rounds up their top most viral
pins for the Halloween season and I
picked three of those food items that
I'm gonna make today to see if it's
really worth it do they look really cute
do they taste really good and are they
practical to make now I am NOT a chef by
any means I am pretty far from it but I
am an avid Pinner they claim to be like
that anybody can make these and you can
totally make them and bring them for
your next party I'm gonna see if that's
true the first recipe that I'm doing are
these Pizza skulls
you know pizza rolls that you like
making the microwave imagine a really
big version of that and it is shaped
like a skull let's do it first step is
to unroll the pizza dough and press into
a 5 by 10 inch rectangle and cut into 6
strips it's not a right thing coupe oh
my gosh what was when all the continents
were put together Pangaea that's kind of
what this looks like okay there we go
that's what I'm talking about I'm using
the word rectangle loosely here because
this is a little blobby but it's pretty
much a rectangle and now we're gonna cut
it into six strips I was a little skimpy
with this last piece of dough my
rationing was a little off I'm skeptical
about the amount of dough it tells you
to use because right now these strips
are pretty thin this is actually a very
easy recipe it's basically just making
pizza in this glorified muffin tin there
we go that's what I'm talking about now
we're gonna fill our pizza skulls
sprinkle with a little cheese like
define a little cheese though you know
like a little cheese to me it's probably
a lot of cheese to somebody else
[Music]
I'm gonna do half of the skulls with
meat and half of them without me now I'm
just gonna fill up the rest of the
skulls with cheese
definitely noting which one is the
cheesiest and saving it for myself now
I'm gonna put in the oven at 375 for
about 20 minutes
the skulls have just come out of the
oven the dough looks tasty they don't
look like anything from the backside so
I have to take them out of the mold to
see if it actually looks like a skull
[Music]
you can't see this but everyone around
me is like thank you will you pry my
skull it's really cute I'm being
frustrated by the look
okay aha pizza rolls on hydraulics for
Halloween this is doom I did notice that
the ones with meat in them are much
grease here and there a little bit
Messier and the skull like doesn't look
as clean so if I did this again I would
probably do just cheese and sauce
because you look really neat and crisps
obviously this goes without saying but
these skull pizza is definitely pinnable
now onto recipe number two this is
chicken boo bill soup haha I made that
bowtie pasta because it supposed to look
like a little bat the next step is to
dye the pasta black and we're gonna do
that by putting all this pasta in a big
ziploc bag with a lot of black food
coloring and then shaking it around
there we go
now I'm gonna cut the vegetables into
cute little shapes cut too shallow lines
about 1/4 inch apart from each other
whoa okay this log goes from like
peeling and chopping priam it's a
pumpkin there are a few visuals that are
missing from this to shallow lines okay
I think I'm getting it it's not easy
like at all so I've kind of got the
grooves that should create the stem
hopefully pumpkins will emerge from this
but I don't know I'll believe it when I
see it you know what I'm saying oh no
that's so cute oh my god very excited
about this that [ __ ] is cute
and then next I'm gonna cut celery and I
don't really actually need to do
anything because when you pop up celery
it looks like a little moon celery is
not really looking like moons at all
[Music]
there's a lot going on I don't like
little pumpkins I love the black noodles
I'm scared of the noodles sog the look
is cooler than the taste but this way it
looks like I'm left knowing you look at
this way it looks like chicken noodle
soup it's in a bowl now we're on to our
third and last recipe and those are some
deviled eggs that are meant to look like
little alien eggs gently crack the
hard-boiled eggs with a knife or by
rolling them on the counter I'm gonna
try the counter method first these are
never gonna crack so now we only have 5
eggs
I'm afraid I'm gonna put my thumb right
through this whole egg
I don't know what to do okay I'm gonna
try the nice method oh this works okay
looking like little dragon eggs
so we've boiled our eggs we cracked our
eggs and now we're gonna color the eggs
[Music]
now it's time to peel these eggs and see
if all of our hard work paid off and if
this really cool pattern is on there wow
that is so cool I'm very happy about
this now face them just to make deviled
eggs
[Music]
deviled alien eggs I love it these are
so pretty
do that pattern that is really good it
should be a crowd-pleaser Marianne
Thieme it also tastes cream
I am really happy about it
the deviled alien eggs are definitely
pinnable I have been on Pinterest long
enough to know that there are some
Pinterest BS being pinned around there
but these totally work they were super
fun to make they tasted really good and
they look even cooler what more can you
really ask of a Halloween recipe
[Music]